[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting man we are going to tackle
a deep dark issue we're gonna seek to
answer the question or at least explore
it in detail with a scope like device of
conversation that question is our farts
actually funny are they actually funny
and you know I I want this I'm going to
start echoing I think we should do that
because I've heard that Ren order for
people to remember things you have to
say it multiple times something now on I
don't think my needs to remember that
our farts actually our farts actually
funny and I you know I don't I don't
want to just be a bunch of like to
school kids we're out of being idiots I
wanna I want to be sophisticated about I
mean this is I've got historical data I
have I've got information about the
first joke ever recorded I've got
information about the atitude historical
attitudes towards farts and media blow
your fart and mine and I have a lot of
experience with farting you know the
average person farts 14 times a day and
everyone will deny that it is that many
you said what 10 to 20 14 well 10 to 20
is I read 10 to 20 yeah 14 is you know
as an average I think I probably farted
14 times just today when we were talking
a little bit about farts earlier oh well
a wise man once said laughter is like
farting from your mouth yeah that was
you link your wise man a wise man once
quoted himself in the third person
saying something about farts did you
know did you really actually did you
notice that as we were talking about
this and kind of in looking at the
research that we were standing in our in
our office yeah and there was multiple
audible farts coming from you
yeah
but it was know I'm done for me and I'm
from you today maybe but I was just
getting into the spirit of this whole
thing you know but then I started
realizing that it's typical that that's
how it is in our office when no one else
is in our office is that there's open
it's an open farting policy I want to
get back to this okay I don't want to
get into it right now because I'm glad
that you admitted that you have you have
an issue an issue I wanted to explore it
I had they don't think it's an issue I
had the vegan so you think it sunset
bowl from green lab or whatever it was
when the sunset quinoa dries broccoli
all right so we're gonna get into
farting but it's gonna be sophisticated
it's gonna be adult and it's gonna be
you just made the word adult sound it's
gonna be life-changing that it was I
don't know it didn't make me think more
about farts okay
but I do I have to say that I'm gonna
have trouble I'm having trouble turning
I'm doing the Batman thing that I have
to do sometimes but Batman swivel where
the shoulders turn with the nose yeah
because I earlier today when I was at
the gym getting my bubble and it's not I
think I hurt I hurt my upper back now as
you know upper back I've got lower back
issues that I that I've dealt with on
and off and I have a recurring upper
back everybody
I assume like I know you got like your
shoulder thing and you kind of know when
it's about to happen and you know when
it's happened and it's very specific and
isn't a certain place and then pain
radiates in exactly the same way every
time
but just just as a side note for those
of you don't know my shoulder there's an
ant in my cup will pop out a socket and
then pop right back in it's like the
ligaments got to get it there it is okay
all right he's flinging it on the floor
and now he's drinking a big gulp of the
drink without the end okay but a residue
ever since attempting to benchpress
as a middle schooler my my right
shoulder would just pop out and pop back
in but anyway
concerting and i yeah now I have I have
issues from how I slept on it but I've
actually in in trying to take care of my
body and you know watch what I'm eating
and doing the Pilates and now I'm going
to this I be going to the gym and
meeting with this personal trainer who's
like focusing on like my back health and
posture and things wealth and knowledge
those personal tires I haven't I haven't
had the upper back issue in quite some
time it's something that would happen
even in college I remember the first
time it really happened and I thought
that I was down for the count was when
we were watching UFC we got into
watching UFC in college and we would
watch it and then we would wrestle and
other other guys in the dorm room would
come in and there would be like other
people would sometimes join in on it it
was very strange now that I think about
it but I was trying to get in you like
almost like a suplex kind of thing but
we never really did any real moves it
was just like kind of like grappling you
know like sparring but in putting and
pulling up I felt this little snap right
in between my shoulder blades just to
the right of my spine and that was when
I thought that I wasn't gonna be able to
make it to class the next day oh because
it hurt so bad it's not nearly that bad
but I was not doing a pull-up is doing
something short of a pull off so you're
saying that's when your upper back
injury originated I've had the upper and
the lower back since like high school
college oh I didn't know you I didn't
know you had an upper back thing sharp
pain anyway and then when I get it
turning both ways causes this really
sharp pain in the middle which is much
better because I've been like you see me
massaging myself all day you didn't
offer to help
by the way somebody's been sitting here
massaging myself but I am I was doing a
pull-up but not a pull-up it's just the
exercise was just jump up and hold
yourself up like you're doing a pull-up
mm-hmm and hold it for five seconds and
let yourself down gently and then like
like a reverse chin up the third down
the third one felt the snap it was like
oh no no no no no Bannos and then I'm
like I'm
like an old man at that point and I'm
like I don't know what else I can do
Oh was the trainer there yeah and then I
might also my knees kind of hurting and
my lower back was already hurting from
from earlier and I was just like I think
I should just quit today and Digi well
she ended up like giving me some
modified things just to fill the time
and she had to make that money I ended
up being she's like I know you're you're
decrepit and you're falling apart here
but I gotta get that money ultimately
what I'm saying is if you see me
touching myself during this podcast it's
just because I'm trying to comfort my
own spine and I'm gonna be fine
don't worry about me and you said your
sympathies appreciate it but wait I turn
to you like this I might use the swivel
in the chair and it's just because this
hurts more than normal I don't mean to
look at you with a blank on empathy text
air but that's that's I just can't
conjure up anything else right now I
think I think somehow this is you
deserved this and you know I didn't want
to say that out loud I know it would be
a great superpower a great superpower
would be able to snap your fingers and
make someone else feel exactly what
you're feeling oh so I could be like and
then you'd be like oh I'm gonna take it
back now speaking of Thanos imperfect
empathy we'd be like a USB port there is
that I mean like the empath superhero in
guardians but she can feel your pain she
can't make you feel her pain that's
pretty self-centered keep saying Thanos
I said I said Thanos earlier and then I
said speaking of Thanos like oh oh
I'm talking I'm talking in them in the
Marvel Universe and what in what is what
is that superheroes name she's the one
with the antenna and the big eyes oh and
the weird bald head thing oh no yes oh
yeah hey part of the crew would she's
like pink ish yeah she was on Thanos his
head man yeah you never fan us I spoke
of him you keep Thanos the snap you said
the snap earlier I get it I am just I am
really sore myself
but I have not sustained an injury
because in in my my gym experience
yesterday morning I had to do some
pull-ups real pull-up oh my gosh man if
you haven't done pull-ups if you want to
get sore do a do a bunch of pull-ups
having not done pull-ups for like a
couple of years and it it'll just
ransack you man like everything
underneath my armpits is just like it
just just a tender place of emotion it's
like just poke anywhere I'm liable just
to start crying man but something feels
good about it like you were talking
about last week you were tomahawk can't
walk because they have me doing
one-legged squats awful I just recovered
that's the thing did you like it didn't
you did you like there wasn't an aspect
of liking the soreness like I can
actually I actually feel like I have
some muscles I was um I like soreness in
general but it was it was extreme it was
like I couldn't go upstairs it was that
bad and it was that bad for like I mean
I did go upstairs but I had to really
use the arm rails it was like three or
four days and I'd finally gotten over it
and then I'm freaking injure myself you
got to watch it man more character you
let any farts out like when you're
straining so much to like do a pull-up
or do some of that Pilates that you do I
mean to get back to the farts to just
start to stuff to whet our appetite for
the hub please don't use fartin and wet
right after it it was an H in there I
think it's wet no I actually I think
about a gladden appetite you wet it I
actually think about it quite often
you're holding him in oh yeah in the
morning time that's like prime time and
that's like deflation time it's like
you're like equalizing like a scuba
diver at their first like 2 or 3 hours
that you're awake I mean maybe it's just
because I'm six foot seven do you eat
something before you go in to the gym
because I think I actually don't have a
fart problem usually I have a stink
problem like if I eat garlic the night
before yeah you me not from the stink
from everything from my whole body
but I don't have a fart bro I mean it's
not I mean I had oatmeal today before I
went in but I mean definitely there were
a few there were a few times when I was
like if I was in here alone I would let
it go right now but I'm not going to I
don't not gonna put however during the
end of the workout while the what
happens in in my gym is after you you
work out your trainer stretches you
makes you feel like a professional
athlete oh and they line you up there's
like four stretching tables and usually
they're pretty full you know weekday
morning around 7:00 a.m. or whatever and
so on a table not even on the floor
you're on this like table like a like a
physical therapy tape yeah and they're
stretching you and Wow
someone they don't do that in my gym
someone next to me like that the people
the trainer and the and the patient what
do you call him client over here to the
right of me it's one of them farted and
it came over towards us was it audible
no I could it went in my right nostril
so I was able to like echolocate the
fart I knew where it came from right and
I knew that it wasn't my trainer and it
wasn't me but I was like she might think
that it's me because it definitely
smelled like a dudes fart because it
just there's just a difference and well
hold on now there's just a difference
well it's like that's so sexist
ultimately what I think farts stink man
no what I'm saying is if like smelly if
there was if there was a bear that got
into my house and there was a deer that
got into my house I kind of feel like
ultimately I'd be able to tell you if it
was a bear or a deer and I feel like men
have like bear farts sometimes not all
men but some men so then I was like
should I say something like it wasn't me
no you can't do that so I just I just
began to stretch a little more I never
to waft it away I definitely would I
would have said something but now that
I'm saying that I'm like I have been I
have been hit with the opportunity to
like he explained that it wasn't me but
then I'm also worried that it's them and
I'm putting them on the spot so then
it's like well
I'm putting them on the spot to lie if
it was them and then if they don't lie
it's extremely embarrassing so the
reason why I don't do it is for that
reason to not make the other person feel
like I'm back at only to acknowledge it
but if you had Eko located the thing
then I think you should have just you
should you should have let that rip hey
it wasn't me
yeah it was that guy over there it was
one of them two feet away from us okay
you should have done that man so we've
already gotten into farts a little bit
here and I think that is there any
comedy in that I think there was
something I think me saying the term
echolocate a fart probably made some
people laugh yeah that wasn't my
intention necessarily but it is the way
it came out just like a little but
that's for them to say yeah and you but
was it funny I don't know you be the
judge I was asking was it funny for you
to experience it not did you just say
something no but our farts funny okay
our first year so us talking about that
oh yeah I think we talked about it for
comedic effect and I think we were
fishing for some comedy and I do think
we're gonna be talking a lot I don't
know if we echolocate farting being a
corporate farting specifically being
incorporated into purposeful comedy oh I
think is a big part of this discussion I
don't think it's just like is it funny
when someone farts and why is it funny
we'll get into that but is it funny to
then make fart jokes is it funny to have
a fart joke in your pants ready to flip
it out and impress somebody well let's
get into that but first let's take a
moment to draw your attention to this
ear biscuit jar I got one too look at
that
you need to get one of these in mythical
dot store because once you get it you
can drink out of it just like we're
doing right now even if there's an ant
in it I feel like us by drinking out of
an ear biscuit jar when you drink out of
something and it has uni have a personal
connection to it that would be to us it
makes whatever you taste better mmm I
don't believe that we can say this
according to like the FDA from us it
makes what you drink out of it
psychologically tastes better because
you're gonna remember what I'm saying to
you right now
and well you're gonna open your cupboard
and you're gonna see this ear biscuit
jar up there and you have other options
of what to drink out of and you're gonna
choose it because it connects you to us
FTC action to this moment Federal Trade
Commission I think I need to legally say
and it's psychologically gonna taste
better because you're tasting not only
the taste of the thing you're tasting
but you're also tasting the experience
of an air biscuit these claims have not
been proven in a lab and this is just
what we put on the label to make you
feel better about drinking out of the
cup
I'll tell you something that was 100%
true we have less than a thousand as you
say that is true and then once they are
gone we're not making any more so be a
part of history if you want this to sit
in your cupboard oh gosh how did you how
did you do that this is it I'm spilling
it everywhere magic cupboard don't don't
try it again okay mystical dot store all
right I thought that we could so we've
had a few things right we've got
personal farting stories but I don't
even feel like we should get into those
because we don't even know if they're
funny yet because we haven't we haven't
even explored if it's okay for farting
to be funny for fart jokes to be funny
which is kind of what we're getting into
so there's the stories there's also our
personal philosophy would like our
comedy and how we like what how do we
view farts and in our comedy or
repertoire but then also kind of like
the history of farting and in comedy and
people's viewpoint on it what do you
think makes the most sense in terms of
getting it - first let's set the stage
with some some cultural analysis of
farts through the through the through
the strata of comedy okay good idea
now I I got some of this from do we post
like sources anywhere we don't do do we
good I mean a tweet an article if you'd
like okay
your biscuit I'll do that when this when
this comes out I'll talk about it but
right now I've dude that had this
article from the Pacific Standard which
talks about a few of these things and
then there's another article that I'm
not remembering at the moment but you
can get this information in multiple
places first of all I one of the things
I found really interesting is that Jimmy
Pardo remember Jimmy Pardo who wrote we
were on his his podcast yeah never not
funny and and then we did his uh his
fundraiser a charity thing his marathon
in this article in the Pacific Standard
by a gun guy named Rick Paulus he was
talking about how some comedians really
really hate fart jokes and Jimmy Pardo
was quoted as saying I don't think there
is a topic I hate more and you can quote
me he's like really really adamantly
against fart jokes really and you know
who's also just against bathroom humor
in general is Jimmy Jimmy Fallon another
Jimmy maybe if you're Jimmy there's a
new theory you don't you don't like
bathroom humor but my dad's name is
Jimmy and he'll fart up a storm but does
he make jokes about it or does he do it
for comedic effect both so it doesn't
hold true bad theory but Jimmy Pardo and
Jimmy Fallon neither of them are into to
fart humor but interestingly the first
joke ever recorded in sumeria 1900 BC
was quote something which has never
occurred since time immemorial
a young woman did not fart in her
husband's lap seemed to get lost in
translation that little that was the
entire joke that's it something which
has never occurred since time immemorial
a young woman did not fart in her
husband's lap this is ringing a bell I
think you've told me about this sir this
has come up before
I've heard this yeah I don't exactly
understand what the joke is there we
didn't figure it out then and I don't
think we're gonna figure it out I can
say that my wife didn't necessarily fart
on my lap but she did fart on a dude's
lap in high school and she tells that
story and it's a funny one well yeah
it's a funny one yeah well I mean how
did that happen told you she didn't tell
me you said there was a story she has
tell me the story
all I know is that she set on a dudes
lap and shortly thereafter she farted
everyone started laughing and it's a
story that is told time immemorial it
apparently it was funny in Sumeria but I
think that the bottom line with that is
the as far back as we can go
two people recording a joke it was a
fart joke so this is something that this
isn't a new thing I don't think anybody
thought that but it's interesting also
did you know that Shakespeare was in
diverticulitis he was not above a fart
joke I had to just I mean there were
multiple ones to choose from there were
a little bit subtle almost like a silent
fart that's because we don't understand
Shakespeare but in Othello
that's a board game right the clown says
are these prey you win instruments and
the first musician says I marry they are
sir
clown says Oh thereby hangs a tale first
musician says whereby hangs a tale sir
and the clown says Mary sir by many a
wind instrument that I know he's talking
about the anus butthole yeah
and how it's fart it's like a wind
instrument the fart took us and this is
just again one of many examples that you
can find of bathroom humor
they might even go as far as to call it
Scottish gotta talk it's got a collage
can you say that word for me
eschatological nope it's Scottish got it
illogical
it's got it illogical it's got it yep
like ology of the scat yeah of the scat
in Shakespeare have made a lot of these
and then in the we actually talked about
this guy on the the show on GMM before
this French Baker who was known as let
pet the mind or something like that is a
guy who his whole act he was in early
the late 1800s Early 1900s his whole act
was farting yes through a cone he was a
bit he was a baker like a megaphone and
at first he had people who would come to
his bakery and hear him fart and
impressions of musical instruments what
which is the interesting thing to happen
in a bakery
really don't really want to carb-load
after that
Vineet he took his he took his act on
the road and became this national
treasure of France that people like
Sigmund Freud would actually pay to see
while travelling Europe but this wasn't
comedy this was an exhibition it was
comedy oh it was yeah he was I mean yeah
it wasn't just like he would do
impersonations of people of animals of
musical instruments he would blow out a
candle from across the stage yeah but
but a certain point you're no longer
laughing and you're just clapping you're
in awe it's a it's a it's a trick it's
an exhibition of their alan no doubt
there are elements of that without a
doubt but I definitely think that people
thought it was funny I mean a French
Baker farting it was at least
light-hearted I think it was I think it
was more of it but then for most of the
20th century in media farts were
off-limits it was kind of this like last
taboo of something that you couldn't
talk about and he couldn't do in movies
like all like the early film movement
you know no farts no bathroom humor
really no till no scenes in a bathroom
nobody's sitting on a toilet well I
kinda seem probably I'm gonna I just
know that directly addressing the fart
or somebody farting was not something
that happened until 1974 Mel Brooks
Blazing Saddles which was a you know
sort of revolutionary comedy film in a
bunch of different ways this is they had
the first fart in a film well multiple
sources that I looked at said that this
was sort of breaking the seal so to
speak on incorporating farts unashamedly
into media into comedy well they
incorporated is an understatement that
verb under cells how many farts they put
into that farting scene yeah we just we
watched it a second ago and the dudes
are the Cowboys are around the fire
eating beans oh yeah and it's a slow
zoom out and like the
there's burping as well there's a burp
and then there's a fart and then there's
a bunch of farting yeah and then the guy
comes out of the tent you probably won't
find it funny just because it hasn't
translated a whole very well at least
that particular scene but it was
revolutionary in the sense that it was
like Mel Brooks was taking a chance and
saying I'm gonna do it we're gonna have
all these actors fart and you know what
it makes me think of just to flash
forward in time a little bit in terms of
great points of flatulence in cinema hmm
I think about that freaking Eddie Murphy
movie where he plays all the different
characters at the dinner table nutty
professor nutty professor and it is it
his mom or his dad or the does the whole
family start farting there's a dinner
scene where multiple actually have a
Nutty Professor written down all I
wanted to use it as an example yes I
just thought about my name I just
remembered dying
that was so funny man because one fart
will catch you off guard I mean and that
checks the box of a certain type of
comedy which is surprised you take
somebody by surprise you add a little
embarrassment into the mix especially
you know and then all of a sudden you're
laughing but then I remember with that
scene it just kept happening
it kept farting and I just remember
belly laughing like I just couldn't I
couldn't stop it was so funny the first
time of course watching it again would
you laugh in that way probably not right
I don't think I don't know if I would
crack a smile if I watch The Nutty
Professor right now I mean speaking of
bathroom humor it's like when I
rewatched a league of their own with the
kids a few months back and I remember
the Tom Hanks scene where he he starts
peeing in the women's locker room and
the whole like team he's he's been on
like a drunk drunken binge and he pees
and he and it just keeps going and going
and going and I remember the theater
like there was like rolling
after it hits you again I actually talk
about a wave I've talked about this
scene multiple times in my life because
it was it was very formative to me as a
aspirational peer right because you
haven't been at a P very long and it
stopped and then it started again but
then when I rewatched it with them
because I knew that it was going to end
at some point I didn't have just the big
question mark of I can't believe this is
still going when is it gonna end
same thing with all the farts and Nutty
Professor once you know it's just a
bunch of farts you kind of roll your
eyes well and you kind of got it this a
little bit you - why farts are funny and
there's a number of theories about first
of all like theories of humor and
theories of comedy are super complex and
there's lots of disagreement mm-hmm
but I do think that farts have two
things number one they're relatable so
there's a relate ability to farts that
across all cultures all times because
everyone's got to get rid of the gas and
there but yeah at some point it's kind
of it's it's like the the gross version
of saying everybody puts their pants on
one leg at a time right but it's even
more relatable releases air pockets
because not everybody where they're an
anus there are cultures that don't wear
pants sure everyone has a butthole
better than and gas comes out of it so
your butthole is like the is like the
pants of the galaxy the galaxy pants of
the galaxy but in the second thing
besides relatability is what you've
called surprise which when discussed in
theories of humorous called pattern
disruption and that's what makes fart
has those two things in full supply
right
not just the gas but it's got the
relatability then it's got the pattern
disruption it causes this sense of
surprise which elicits laughter and we
don't know exactly but it's just that's
why when you put a fart into church
that's like they'll go over like a fart
in church the old euphemism goes when
you put a fart into something that
humans have dressed it up to be formal
and to have a certain level of
expectations that were not all thinking
about each other's buttholes at the time
like we're doing the least think about
each other's buttholes thing that we can
come up with like being Church yeah or
we're at a newscast or a formal dinner
or something like that and then all of a
sudden somebody farts there's no
question as to what it is you don't have
to speak any particular language to know
that was a fart that came from that
dudes butt and that surprised us and
disrupted this pattern that we've got
going on uh-huh and everyone begins to
laugh and that's why it's universally
funny so I think the first part of the
question is are they actually funny well
yeah they're funny I think it depends
because well I'm curious if we if if our
upbringing and how we interacted with
farts over the course of our lives
has primed us to find farts funny
because I don't think there's any secret
that we find farts funny right but not
in every instance but not all fart we
have a general predisposition to find
farts funny and I think at least for me
it has to do with my upbringing mm-hmm
so I and I'm curious about yours but for
me my both of my granddad's would just
when I go visit my grandparents they
would just I mean they would just do
these reverberatory farts that we would
just all get a kick out of it like my my
mom's dad and my dad's dead they would
just they would just rip them and
everyone would immediately laugh and I
mean they were so expressive I mean when
you when you get a laughing that way you
start to know how to harness that pocket
of air for for for maximum of effective
it becomes a tool but my Nana she'd also
rip them but now she's at a point and
I've I've you know you fast-forward to
this point in her life great-great
grandmother just walking around doing
whatever she wants farting just doing
the walking farts every step well yeah
god bless her not eat once it's not even
for comedic effect anymore but we kind
of we laugh at her we kind of snicker
because it's happening and sometimes
she'll like cut her eyes but
I mean it just comes from a long line of
fart a fart is followed by a laugh in
the Neal household but now in my house i
I I operate that way I fart I expect to
get a laugh but you know what it doesn't
happen and my kids will say well it's
gross it's gross
so I I I think that I don't know they
just haven't been around enough people
laughing at it and they've only
experienced the negative parts which are
the like the smell part well as an
aspect I have a theory I have a theory
for why your kids don't find it funny
but I don't want to get there yet okay
and I so I kind of give you my my
backgrounds very similar I mean I didn't
have as I wasn't close to my grandpa my
grandparents didn't live in the same
town and so honestly like when I think
about like my I know that my my grandma
mom and l's husband but my step granddad
we call pop he definitely farted I
remember him sitting in like a recliner
in farting but it was just like a a
handful of visits and it was funny there
was absolutely no shame associated with
flatulence right in in the families that
in my immediate family and also the
families that we were related to and
which is usually usually you just say
extended relatives wait at least that
was related but well your well your
parents did you grow up with your
parents farting yeah yeah yeah well like
both of them both of them yes now my dad
would do it for for you know comedic for
you know comedy sake comedic punctuation
and he might there might be like well
you know what I think about that you
know well-placed fart when my mom wasn't
great I think it might have been like it
wasn't always on purpose but when it was
it was immediately acknowledged and
diffused with a laugh so we weren't one
of those families I was ashamed of farts
unless it felt like more than a fart
happened there was certainly a glass see
with shart happen okay at that point
there's some shame involved and it is
still very funny yeah but it's
different kind of laugh I think there
was a glass ceiling for for my mom it's
you know my the the men in my life they
were it seems like they would like hold
them for the perfect moment and just
like let them rip just like just just
force it out and in the most
reverberatory way but I don't I don't
think the women were expected to do that
which is a shame right you know there's
the yeah there's a double standard so
for them it you'd laugh at them because
something slipped out but the men it was
like good lord what have you done I mean
my we were staying a few Christmases ago
we were we spent the night at my dad's
house and all the kids slept in the
sunroom which is like at the back door
and Lincoln tells the story of my dad
who he calls granddaddy coming in and
saying taking his his dog gypsy out and
he's like he said gypsy and that made
Lincoln stir a little bit and then my
dad I don't know how you could have this
much gas inside of your belly and it it
can't be healthy and he let out this
fart that was it was like a huge deposit
I mean it could have filled up the whole
sunrooms like
started again and then it woke up
Lincoln it woke him up was like an
earthquake was happening and in my dad
said gypsy and then he let out the fart
and then he was like good lord and then
he just walked out the door yeah you
gotta walk out after that good we don't
want to sit around and discuss it and
aim it in it's scarred Lincoln its
scarred him it scarred him I mean it
didn't literally leave a scar on him he
wasn't that close to it but I the only
farts that my family likes that I do are
the ones that do in my mouth they'll ask
me do that fart in with your mouth did
do that fart mouth cuz I got around kids
it's not like it's like the Waltons it's
like good night daddy
that's it that's it they love it when I
do this fart that comes out of like the
lower right part of my mouth it's pretty
good they love that yeah but when I when
I really fart from my anus
they don't like Oh where's it from
and I think that's why they I think
that's my theory I'm just gonna skip to
my theory wait for you I just think they
know that they smell something I mean
this is gross I'm sorry but I think this
is their they just think there was air
in your anus and now it's in my nose
yeah I don't care how funny it sounded
that is gross well you know what it is
okay and I think I think comic relief is
the only way to get over that reality
well I think that's my argument for it I
think there are two I think there are
two two reasons that your kids don't
find it funny well in and this goes back
to the theory of humor right so one
aspect of the theory of humor is or
someone's theory of humor is that things
that are funny involve something going
wrong with no one getting hurt mmm-hmm
right so somebody falling down the
stairs sometimes it hurts somebody
falling down the stairs and dying it's
not funny but somebody falling down the
stairs and not dying or not getting hurt
is funny yeah it's just the outcome
so when your flatulence is stanky and is
experienced by your kids in a negative
way they're getting hurt right so it's
like it may start as funny but then when
it's like oh that actually stunts this
is unpleasant it's no longer funny but I
actually think an even bigger part of it
and this is why I wanted to use the
Nutty Professor because I remember
laughing at that but I would not laugh
at it now is I think that because a key
up to a fart being funny is this pattern
disruption but when the fart becomes the
pattern it's no longer funny so if you
go to the fart too often as I do believe
Eddie Murphy does too much in the Nutty
Professor hmm
in that one scene and potentially you
may do too much as the farting dad in
your house you're wearing out the farts
welcome by going to it so often and now
it's no longer disrupting a pattern but
the pattern has become dad farts for
attention yeah and if you're farting if
you're farting on a regular basis so
it's for in other words in other words
like if you had a friend and it was like
the first time you ever met this guy you
walk into the room and he farted he
would laugh and you would tell the story
but if every time you walked into the
room he farted and that was his thing
you're like I don't want to go into the
room anymore it's unpleasant it's also
not funny because I'm expecting it in an
expected fart is it funny
I also think that it's really hard in a
cinematic setting to make a fart funny
because it's you well everything's
calculated so if you're deciding to go
with the fart joke in that moment it
better be really good and surprising and
original in some way it just can't be
like adding a fart sound effects when
when Jar Jar Binks runs off scene which
I I do have a memory that being a part
of the Star Wars movie that Jar Jar
Binks
they put a fart sound in at one point is
this true I believe there's a fart noise
yes I'm pretty certain of it and that's
just okay that's just cheap it's like
okay what the kids find it funny when
this character farts you know and also
who's the
likely character to fart charge our
banks don't give him the fart right the
fart to the most unexpected character
and maybe you're getting somewhere Darth
Maul yeah if Darth Maul farts I'm laugh
at that all day but Star Wars isn't a
comedy shouldn't have ever tried to be
one and that's why we that's why that
dude's life was like ruined like you're
the parts now you told me about the
Geordi I play Jar Jar Binks it I mean he
like had a while back in a horrible life
yeah he can't he he came forward saying
it screwed up his screwed up his life it
so it is a thing Jar Jar Jar Jar Binks
fart you'll get it you know all you want
but we met in real life farts can be
hilarious like I mean if I search TV
fart bloopers I can watch videos of
newscasters or people in like a
talk-show setting accidentally farting
and hilarious I looked at those before I
came here and and I thought to myself as
long as I'm seeing a fresh clip I've
never seen the laughs are not gonna stop
because you get the facial expression
and the beauty beautiful thing is
beautiful thing is you don't smell it
you don't smell it so nobody gets hurt
nobody gets hurt when it's on the other
side of a screen
matter of fact speaking of somebody
getting hurt it can get you fired but it
can make a career I'm sure many ear
biscuit ears have heard about Paul flirt
who has an Instagram account he was he
he's a security guard at a hospital and
he would the story is he would fart when
no one was around at like the the
entrance to the hospital and he realized
how good the acoustics were and he
started turning on his well the shots
the exactly the same exact time so it's
almost like a webcam shot and on if he's
doing it with his phone but it's his
face in the top of his uniform and you
can see like the hospital sign behind
him not all of it just a little bit of
it it's mostly his face
and he just kind of like in an office or
something blinks no you use the reverse
he was in the reception or diverse ocean
and he would each Instagram video is
just one fart mm-hmm but it's I watched
all of them and you saw me over there
cackle and I'm like and when I looked at
my her shoulder it was definitely very
very funny because it's just his face
like blinking and like twitching and
then at his reaction to his own fart and
that's and then whatever caption he
might put on it like ferocious felt that
one in my chest anyways he starts he
starts getting big on on on the internet
people put compilations on YouTube and
whatnot he's got 74 thousand followers
on Instagram as of this recording but
that was plenty to get him fired well
which he then live-streamed as it was
happening getting fired
getting getting kicked out of the
hospital yeah so now he's trying to make
a living
harder as a farmer he's got a patreon he
given five dollars and it I got fired
you're really paying me to fart thank
you that's what it says five dollars a
month or you can give him one day it
seems like he could he could start a job
somewhere so a place you know like a
like a like a glue factory we we
actually knew a guy Oh cuz of the stink
who worked at a glue factory which just
smells absolutely horrible because of
the things that go into glue and he said
that the best thing about it was if you
had one that you knew wasn't gonna make
any noise you're in a board room and
people were just constantly letting him
fly because it was masked by this I
think that he needs to be a security
guard at a glue factory and then it's
the best of both worlds and everybody's
happy I mean if you if you're in a plane
and all of a sudden someone like like
sawed a log mm-hmm that sounds like a
snore but I was trying to come up with a
fart euphemism I don't find that funny
because the paint thing you're exactly
right because we're trapped we're
trapped with you in that in that place
but a video of you not on that plane
watching other people on that plane you
would laugh at it even even if you felt
bad for the people remember Tom eg the
story we tell here sitting I don't
say his last name anymore yugi starts
with the g though sitting on the front
row of miss Ennis's history class I was
sitting in the middle you're sitting
somewhere over to the side all of a
sudden you hear a fart and it was so
loud and so long that everyone in the
class had a chance to stop what they
were doing missing a stop talking and
everybody turned and locked on him and
echo located it directly to the one seat
the one butthole that was emanating this
fart Tommy G it was like well when an
earthquake lasts so long that you can
start to try to keep things from falling
over that's what was happening in the
room it was like a game of Marco Polo
except the person just holds out polo
until you touch them you know it's like
so easy to figure out where they're at
oh and you know what no one was laughing
in the moment but right because it was
so it was unbelievable but then as soon
as it ended it was like the room didn't
erupt out of reverence for I mean that
would have been cruel boat we laughed
about a lot later well but misenus
actually addressed him after he did it
he said something like well Tommy
because she knew - yeah I mean you gotta
say something I feel bad you gotta have
a back pocket line for that because this
is a serious thing how brutal kids can
be you gotta have a back pocket line
like wow that farts coming out and
you're like oh no they're not gonna
echolocate they're gonna know it's me
yeah you got to stand up and bow you
can't let your face get red you got to
stand up you got a bow you got to own it
and people will be telling that story
forever kids are mean ruthless so so do
you fart how to farts go over in your
house now well they get a laugh uh you
know I feel like again not to continue
the sexist commentary but I've got two
boys and at least in my experience they
tend to be a little bit more fart
friendly and the yes so there's just
there's a shaking of the head of my wife
is she now she's she doesn't she's not
uptight about it at all there's no like
we didn't have like a no fart policy
there are many relationships where
there's a no fart policy but we don't
have that in our relationship but I
pretty much any fart in any context gets
a laugh and there's no like oh come on
dad
situation so thus far that that's the
experience but but also based on what
you're telling me I don't feel like I'm
doing it as much as you or that years
aren't as potent and stinky as mine are
I have noticed that you do often smell
like something has died inside of you I
will say that okay I'll take that note I
don't know I'm not exactly sure what the
cause of it is you might have to see a
doctor but I gotta say I do have a
locking I can have significant volume
and I can have significant force and I
can have significant frequency but I
don't often have significant stink
unless I'm sick I don't know what it is
like I stopped drinking regular milk
almond milk yeah when the oat milk yep
milk I think that helped you think yeah
yeah cuz there he does contribute to it
so so you don't you don't have an issue
with the under the bedspread what you
like I mean I'm not saying I haven't
ever Dutch toughened Dutch oven to my
wife yeah I haven't tried it I try to
seal it down I like I put my elbows on
top of the covers and like pull it down
and then flap your foot so it goes out
look yeah yeah that's right okay I see
the plan that doesn't work too well but
I think it'll seep out I think we've
established that we personally find
farts funny in real life and also in
media that is depicting real life so
mm-hmm but to get back to what you're
talking about a second ago which is
the scripted fart the scripted fart joke
yeah
bathroom humor because I'm gonna I'm
gonna widen out a little bit into
bathroom humor in junior in general and
call me junior and and junior let me
tell you this I think so just a little
bit about our philosophy of humor in the
way that we've approached our comedy so
very early on we kind of made a
conscious decision to not go into
certain places with our comedy right you
may have noticed that we don't really do
political jokes we don't really do
religious jokes we don't really get into
controversial things as a as a policy I
mean every once in a while we may hint
at something or there's no break this
seal on something there's no it
intentionally shocking humor right the
shock jock stuff and we're also not
cynical like our humor is not cynical I
mean I might get a little cynical at
times but in general we don't have a
cynical point of view when it comes
through our comedy and then also we
don't get overtly sexual obviously and
you watch the show you know there's a
lot of innuendo that happens naturally
that we kind of embrace and have
embraced even more as the years have
gone by but it's not overtly sexual it's
not overtly blue it's not r-rated and so
when you sort of box yourself in you
then have to think to yourself well what
am I going to do what lines am I going
to cross and so you naturally end up
because right humor is about crossing
lines first of all a big part of it is
about defying norms and crossing lines
so you're going to building someone once
you build a box like you've described
for us it's got a fart its way out he's
one winner squeeze the box it's gonna
like an accordion
yeah the box that we put ourselves in a
little you know not not to Weird Al is
like the comedy and so the comedy often
comes out in the form of bathroom humor
so not necessarily fart jokes but there
are you know we get into
bathroom humor and some people are like
that's not my thing I wonder sometimes
when people are like I'm not in the
bathroom humor
I'm not into blue stuff I'm not into
sexual humor I'm not into religious
humor
I'm not into political humor I'm
beginning to wonder well what makes you
laugh
I don't know where where else no we do
have other stuff in our yeah yeah no I'm
just I don't necessarily there's some
people who are like I don't like
bathroom humor I'm grossed out by and I
never find it funny
that's their prerogative I'm just I'm
honestly I would want to talk to that
person to be like okay well what what is
the funniest thing for you and is it
something that doesn't cross a line
because I don't that doesn't compute for
me but we've tried I would ask that
person if you're watching jeopardy I'm
not assuming they watched jeopardy just
because they don't have a sense of humor
right but let's say you pass by a
television Jeopardy's on you're not even
tending to watch it Alex Trebek's asking
he doesn't ask a question because they
get to the answer gives the answers man
yeah you got to get that right or else
you get it wrong he's in the middle of
an answer any farts yeah
burnt would you find that funny would
you find that funny I think most people
would I would that would be like top 10
like if I told you that was on YouTube
and that I found it hilarious and honest
you'd go you you'd search it right yeah
I'm searching it right now uh because if
it's happened I want to know can you
google Alex Trebek fart see what comes
up because well okay feel like I might
be onto something like my future is it
it I'm sure it's one of those remember
the who's the preacher it's probably
somebody adding it to like who's that
preacher that the televangelists ooh yes
and they makes like though
no way he makes like the faces and she
proved God
and God and then they just put a bunch
of fart noises every time you see that -
Tilghman Robert knows name farting
preacher if you google farting preacher
to probably be the first thing that
comes up but it now that's an added joke
of course he's not really farting but
his face looks so contorted that it and
it's time so well just it's so great
splendid but let's talk about the times
when it hasn't worked for us because the
the prime example of this yeah that's
him what's his name Tilton Tilton when
it hasn't worked for us is when we
leaned into it so heavily on this thing
that we did called first-date farts I
really liked it did you just fart no it
was a notification that was a while back
it was a it was when it was within the
context of a GMM but it was like a short
like two minutes sketch where we're in
the car you're playing a woman on a date
with me and you're covering up the fact
that you're farting by saying that it's
my ringtone my ringtones and my text
messages and stuff and yeah I'm pretty
sure that this that idea came from a
conversation that Cassie was having with
Stevie that's my memory that sounds
right he's that Cassie Cassie has an
idea
this TV related to us and then we turned
it to that sketch and it's again I think
did Yuri watch it I didn't work it was I
don't know I don't like leaning into it
that much because that's when I believe
that you are getting into a place where
you the surprise is taken out of it yeah
that that's my best assessment of that
is that when you get that joke and then
you just run it into the ground and
that's the whole sketch the pattern
disruption element is gone because the
pattern becomes the fart becomes the
pattern and at that point I'm not that's
why if you watch a movie that relies too
much on it and it becomes the pattern
itself it just it it it's not sacred
anymore there's nothing unexpected about
it keep the fart sacred it's it's it it
can be cheapened but we can reclaim that
do you remember Sundance two years ago
when Swiss Army man premiered mm-hmm oh
yeah at Sundance and we were trying to
figure out what we were gonna go watch
we're gonna we were trying to figure out
what yams are gonna go and you started
and the way Sundance worse is you're
just you're in line with people you're
talking to people so you end up saying
asking them what they've seen and
there'll be they'll literally be a buzz
around me better chatter around movies
that you have to see and all the chatter
about Swiss Army Man at least from the
people that we met was its we heard it's
not good and it's really gross and
there's like this scene at the beginning
where like there's a dead body that's
farting and it's really really gross and
it's like was weird and you shouldn't
see it like that was like the sentiment
from multiple people and I was like what
this sounds stupid I was like we're like
is Alex Trebek and then we didn't end up
seeing it
it's Sundance and then we get back home
and of course like at that point I see
well months pass however however long it
took for from Sundance to the film
actually coming out in theaters which
could have been a year I don't even know
how long it was I see the trailer for
this thing and I'm like this looks like
an incredible movie this looks I have to
see this this looks like right down my
alley or right up it and then we went to
see it and saw the whole scene where the
the dead body is being propelled by
farts like a boat like a freakin jet ski
it was loved it but it was taking a fart
joke to an absolute extreme like an
appalling surreal extreme that a place
that had never gone before it was
completely innovative and so it wasn't a
pattern it was rooted in science too you
know you have a dead bloated body
propulsion which by the way it wasn't a
gruesome dead body it was Dana Radcliffe
who then was the star of the movie
playing a dead guy it wasn't so it
wasn't morbid it was endearingly comedic
absolutely logical imagine it was one
big
fart joke that in my mind worked but I
think it's an illustration of if you're
gonna do a fart joke and you're in
something scripted at this point you've
got to do it in a way that it hasn't
been done before
you can't no one like you can't just
come out with Nutty Professor five and
expect people to still care about it I
mean I didn't see dumb and Dumberer the
most people hated it and I think one of
the reasons that people in a gay I'm
talking to ignorance cuz I didn't see it
is that they kind of went back to the
same well in a lot of ways and there's a
lot of farts in the well I think they
should have never remade the movie
because it's one of those things that
you can't out you can't you can't win
it's a lose-lose situation when you want
to remake a movie like that because they
go back there's so much gross humor okay
we're gonna go back to the exact same
well twenty years later is it still
gonna work no it's not gonna work but if
they were to suddenly do it differently
everybody would criticize them for doing
it differently why you guys trying to
get intellectual with your fart jokes
it wouldn't work so just don't make the
movie just let the movie the original
movie stand on its own so in other words
if you're gonna do if you're gonna bring
farts into comedy purposely now we've
done it accidentally we both
independently farted accidentally on GMM
and it made it into the cut both times
[Laughter]
today - my boys calm did you actually
just yeah he came out yeah because it
was yeah that really worked that was
funny but if you're gonna do it on
purpose
you're gonna write a fart into something
you better do it right yeah that's a
it's like just like threading and
threading a needle if that needle I
don't like to think about does I have a
needle were your sphincter and the yep
the fart joke was I don't know the enema
well I lose the analogy does it matter a
little bit but I think we all know what
you mean so our position on our farts
actually funny seems to be yes they are
intrinsically funny for all the reasons
that we covered but it is the context of
the fart that determines whether or not
it wears its welcome out now I have a
decision to make at this point okay
because I've worked one up oh gosh and
I'm like if I just
of course I'm probably by talking about
it I'm probably bought it I didn't well
I didn't work it up I'm just I find
myself in a position where I could fart
I mean so I think I've already made my
choice because I think that the
alternative would have been don't say
anything like play it cool and then at
the very end as well as we're ending
this episode I could just you know just
punctuate my last sentence with a fart
get your get your honest reactions okay
but it's I guess it's too late for that
now that I've but I mean I don't know it
depends on where you work it in well I'm
not working it in right here cuz you're
you expect it no I can't be looking at
you and it happens you know it needs to
be able to turn my head like Tommy G and
I need to be able to locate you and
where it came from
I'm not I'm not gonna do it but well
Leslie Nielsen of Naked Gun fame and a
lot of other things before that who died
in 2010 had written as his epitaph
epitaph epitaph epitaph gravestone
engraving
let her rip because he was so that his
the fart joke was his thing and he had
like a fart machine that he had with him
at all times and there's actually a clip
that we were watching earlier that I
don't know if it was a real fart or if
it was the fart machine but it's just
he's like being interviewed on
Australian TV
and he just let it rip he just lets it
rip in the middle he's talking about
comedy and he let any and he pauses at a
certain time and just this fart noise
comes and the people don't know how to
interact and he's keep he moves right
along he was the gene he was a genius at
doing that because we didn't know you're
getting into some you didn't know if it
was gonna up @f epitaphs ya know
did I say that yeah okay you didn't know
how they were gonna respond so he wasn't
making a joke he was pulling a prank on
them and the joke would be how they were
spa right and so buddy but you know he
died like he lived he let it rip yeah if
you've got a fart well I don't know how
he died he I think he died of pneumonia
Oh which is like not funny at all oh you
know I'm saying there's like the least
funny way to die I don't know maybe it
was a funny maybe it was a funny nip
pneumonia I'm sure I'm sure this is a
humor in it
Wow what I'm ultimately saying is if you
start talking about potentially laying a
fart into your conversation you're
standing on the shoulders of giants
which is the perfect place to let it rip
actually yeah I mean I'm totally fine
we're just waiting it out and seeing
what happens what what do you mean
waiting it out if I'm gonna fart right
now yeah waiting for like a gopher to
come out of a hole oh oh I'm not gonna
do it I think I'm done with the whole
thing I'm moving on no more fart humor
for me I think you made the right choice
funny wow you're still here listening
thanks for doing that thanks for hanging
out with us let's continue this
conversation online
yeah can we talk more about farts on
Twitter hashtag ear biscuit I'm sure
that many of you have strong this is a
polarizing issue some of you made a
decision to quit listening a while ago
and why I'm not even talking to you
those of you who are still listening
probably either just gave us the benefit
of the doubt or you actually think farts
are funny too let's talk about it and
come to a collective conclusion are we
right are we wrong medicine share was
two of them wasn't oh yeah the first
time it was bigger but you laughed in
the middle of it oh gosh she's not funny
anymore it's over it's ridiculous we're
coming for you Eddie Murphy
[Music]